Hello everyone, my name is Ann and I am a practitioner here at Conner's Clinic and one of the genetic specialists.
So today in this video we are going to be talking about a portion of the genetic review relating to the digestive tract and to gut health.
So just to go over a little bit regarding the importance of gut health, really it is foundational to overall health.
And it is the first place that we begin to address when we're trying to help somebody who has health concerns, you know, they're trying to prevent disease or maybe they have a current chronic condition or an acute condition going on. So we're always looking at gut health. It's where we begin.
And really it starts with the foods that we are eating. So we're eating fats, carbs and proteins, the digestive tract, the job of the digestive tract is to break those nutrients down into small micro nutrients that the can pass through the gut barrier and into the bloodstream.
So the main thing is that the bloodstream ultimately to be circulated throughout the body to individual cells that the mitochondria of those cells will take in those nutrients and ultimately produce ATP.
So ATP is the currency or the energy that our cells need to perform their function.
The gut health and digestion is really important to anything that is irritating to the gut causes a reaction can inflame those cells that line the digestive tract when that happens, the tight junctions that normally link cells together become weakened and things can pass through into the bloodstream that were never designed to be there.
It can send our whole system into a dysfunctional state. And that's where disease can develop.
And so very important to address any gut health issues and to work to reverse leaky gut and it's not something where, oh, I'm addressing gut health for a couple of weeks or a month, I no longer have leaky gut.
And I should be good now. No, this is a lifestyle. We need to constantly be aware of the foods that we're consuming of our bodies response to those foods we need to be working on creating an environment that is healthy and supportive to the digestive tract.
So we are not allowing things to pass that shouldn't. And from a genetic perspective, there's lots of genes that play a role in this whole elaborate system.
So there's genes that help us actually digest the food, break down the food.
There's genes that are related to that leaky gut scenario. There's genes that are affecting the role of the mitochondria and how we're getting the energy that ATP. So a lot of these components are here in the genetic report.
The genes that we're looking at are related to potential for gluten sensitivity. So anybody who has variants on these HLA or the KIA agents, it's really encouraged that you eliminate gluten from the diet gluten is highly inflammatory.
The grains of the past are not the current modernized grains of today. I mean, grains are are sprayed, you know, causing disruptions in the microbiome, causing inflammation.
So avoiding gluten if you have any variants in these genes is highly encouraged.
So this MCM6 gene, if you have variants here, this gene is actually a little confusing because when you have variants here, it actually indicates that your body might be able to be able to break down the lactose component in dairy.
So this gene creates the enzyme lactase, lactase, breaks down that sugar component lactose in the dairy. So we're not looking at casing the protein and dairy with this gene, we're just looking at the sugar component.
Normal expression of this gene is for it to turn off as we age. So we need to be able to use dairy to grow to mature into, you know, our bodies for growth and for maturing into an adult.
And then we don't really need those growth factors from dairy. So the normal expression of this gene is for it to turn off and for us to become lactose intolerant as we age.
So if you do have variants, it actually indicates that your body has left the switch on. So you're more likely to be able to digest lactose if you do have variants in these MCM6 genes.
Now, dairy is still something that can be highly inflammatory. So even if you are perfectly fine as far as digestion, it still can create an environment that is inflammatory within the gut. And that is what we are obviously trying to avoid.
This next section here is looking at mold peanuts caffeine metabolism. So mold and peanut issues are really the same genes here, these peanut allergies. So obviously if you have variants here, you could have a predisposition to developing a peanut allergy, of course, doesn't necessarily variance here, don't mean that you are going to for sure.
Develop that allergy, but you just have a predisposition for it. So best to kind of avoid peanuts or, you know, just make sure that you've got conditions that are gut supportive. So you don't trigger a peanut allergy.
And like I said, these are the same genes that are associated with mold sensitivity. So if you have variants here, you're likely sensitive to mold. So it is very important that you are if you are living in an environment where there's mold.
If you're working in an environment with mold, so any anywhere that you are spending a large chunk of your time need to make sure that there's no mold exposure mold is just very detrimental to health, it creates kind of a highly inflammatory condition that once it's triggered, it's really hard to get out of that vicious inflammatory cycle.
So if you are struggling with something like cancer and you do have variants on these genes here related to mold sensitivity, peanut sensitivity, I would suggest getting a bold test done to just make sure you're not getting some unintended exposure to mold and we need to get that taken care of these genes here related to altered response to caffeine.
So if you have variants here, you might want to watch your caffeine intake just like all other drugs or things that you might have introduced into your body, your body has to break those things down.
And so if we have variants in the pathways that help us metabolize caffeine, then we are going to have an increased response to the caffeine, we might have more of a stimulating effect could contribute to anxiety, could contribute to sleep issues, all of which are not wanted if we are struggling with a health condition or trying to prevent something from being triggered.
So watch caffeine intake, certainly if you are drinking coffee you want to absolutely make sure it's always organic coffee beans are highly sprayed with pesticides, so we want to make sure that we're choosing organic as much as possible.
And this CYP gene is also involved in that process that is metabolizing and breaking down caffeine.
All right, this next gene here BCMO1, so this is a gene that is related to vitamin A and it is how we take beta-carotene and actually convert beta-carotene into vitamin A, which is the act of form that is necessary for cellular health.
And vitamin A is vital to those cells that line the digestive tract, so if you have variants in the BCMO1 genes, you are not taking the beta-carotene from the plant sources, the fruits and vegetable sources, and converting it into vitamin A as well as you should, therefore you could be a little bit vitamin A deficient.
And when we're looking at the cells that line the digestive tract, they really rely on vitamin A for vibrant health, so having variants here can be a predisposition for gut health issues.
You might be taking all of the appropriate probiotics, doing all of the things for gut health, but if you don't have enough vitamin A, these cells just aren't healthy no matter what you're doing.
So this needs to be addressed, if there are variants here, if somebody is taking a course of antibiotics, we need to be really careful with that when you do have issues with this vitamin A conversion gene.
And so taking the right form of vitamin A, that active form, we wouldn't want to supplement with beta-carotene, which is what is mostly found in supplements, that version of vitamin A, people with variants here want specifically to have the active form of vitamin A in retinal form.
ABP1, so this is a gene that helps us to create the DAO enzyme that breaks down histamines within the foods that we're consuming.
So histamines are part of the normal immune response, so anytime there's a potential threat or an antigen that might have been something introduced with the foods that we're consuming.
And mast cells in that area release histamine, so histamine then is signaling for the immune system to come in and to take care of whatever that antigen is surrounding those cells.
So histamine is something that is a normal good response to the body, it is when it becomes out of balance, when we have an over abundance of histamine because of possible variants here, where we don't have the enzyme that breaks down that histamine.
Then we can be signaling for the alerting the immune system and it can create chronic inflammatory conditions.
So if you have variants here, you may start with just by limiting some of the dietary sources, high histamine foods, anything that's fermented or aged, those are going to be in high in histamines.
Vinegar, wine, cheeses, there's some nuts and seeds that are higher in histamines, so you want to address that and start there, you also can supplement.
So if histamines are really an issue for you, you have histamine intolerance, you of course also can take supplements to help with that.
There's other things you can do as well and these are some additional genes, oh, I'll mention before I move on here, there is a gene in this category related to n-sensitivity happens to be this one here, and if you have variants here, you do have a sensitivity to n-sens, meaning you don't metabolize them as well as you should.
So for you need to be a little more careful and you might want to choose some natural alternatives to manage pain, so anything natural that's anti-inflammatory, curcumin, you know, ginger, buzzwellia, resveratrol, high doses of omega-3s, all of those can help manage pain and can be anti-inflammatory.
So if you want to start there, instead of just reaching for that Advil, if you do have that sensitivity to n-sens, more genes relating to histamine metabolism, the HNM-T gene is really related to breaking down histamine within the tissue of the body whereas ABP1 is more related to food and gut health.
HNM-T would be more of an issue if you were exposed to poison ivy, if you react to mosquito bites or bee stings, things like that, so it's in the tissue, and so variants here you still can support the body by lowering your histamine burden overall by lowering dietary intake of histamines.
Like supplementing, we have supplements called natural clear hist or histamine scavenger that can help when you have issues with HNM-T.
And symptoms would be, could be rash, could be heart palpitations, could be migraines, could be sinus congestion, so more than just kind of a skin rash.
There's other things related to histamine within the tissue and you can do a Google search on histamine intolerance and you'll kind of get some more information on that, but certainly histamine can be a huge contributor to a leaky gut scenario.
If we have an over abundance of histamine within the gut, it can combine with dietary gluten and it forms a substance, the combination of gluten and histamine can form a substance called zonulin, zonulin, triggers those tight junctions that we spoke about earlier in between the cells that line the digestive trap, it triggers them to kind of open up and create more of a channel for things to pass through.
And of course this is not healthy, we don't want those channels to be breached because they're there for a reason, they're there to keep the things out that we don't want entering into the bloodstream.
The only things that should be passing into the bloodstream are the micro nutrients from the digestion of foods, you know, and other things that might be beneficial, different vitamins, nutrients, all of those things, you know, fluids, liquid, those types of things, though that's what we want to pass and we don't want microbes, we don't want toxins that can be within the foods, we don't want any of those things to pass.
So if we're opening up those tight junctions, we're just creating a scenario where we're triggering that immune system due to things being in the bloodstream that should not be there, we can have high likelihood of creating autoimmune conditions.
These genes here, M-A-O-A, M-A-O-B, they are also involved in histamine, the histamine process and getting rid of and metabolizing histamine.
So riboflavin is an important co-factor when we're degrading histamine, the M-A-O-A gene helps us to create that optimal riboflavin or vitamin B2 that's necessary, so variants here, you might need to supplement with some B vitamins, M-A-O-B, so variants here, so this sample person here has two genetic variants here.
That indicates a high sensitivity for this gene to not be working as well, and this is relating specifically to some different components of histamines, or really it's amines are kind of an umbrella term for different sources of histamines and phenylethyl amine, listed right here, is kind of under that amine umbrella term.
And so M-A-O-B is specifically working to degrade phenylethyl amine, this can be high in chocolate, so variants here, you might need to be a little more careful with chocolate, sorry.
This person should watch their chocolate intake, that would not be good for me, I love my chocolate.
Let's see, so the rest of these genes to, again just related to different amines and breaking down histamine, so really we're looking at individual genes but we're also looking at how they all interact with each other.
It's important to know that we don't just look at a specific gene and treat that gene, we're looking at the entire pathway that the gene is involved in because once you start trying to manipulate a single gene, there might be some negative downstream effects that you're also influencing, it's kind of like dominoes, you can't really just tip one over if you tip one, really there's an effect that the whole train or the whole pathway is going to be affected in some way or another.
So you have to look at the individual gene but also look at how it's working in its role within the entire pathway, so we're looking at all of these and then also combining it with your symptoms, so some people might have a lot of genetic variance in the histamine genes but they have absolutely zero symptoms of any histamine intolerance.
So their lifestyle is not triggering expression of histamine intolerance, so that's where all of these things that we talk about within the genetic review are very important, it's really empowering to know, okay I have a predisposition for this but if I just change some of my environmental factors or lifestyle factors, then I can really prevent some of these negative things from being expressed.
So you really do have more control over your genetic predispositions, then you might think you are not destined for the diseases of your ancestors, so you have control and with some of these tips that we talk about in the genetic review, it's really setting your body up for optimal, optimal function from a genetic perspective and really working to reverse disease and prevent disease.
This particular gene here, see YP2182 has a, it's related to cortisol and converting progesterone into cortisol, cortisol has a mast cell stabilizing effect, so I mentioned earlier histamine is released from mast cells, and so if we have an issue with histamine, it's a mast cell issue you may have heard of mast cell activation syndrome, so some people who are just so highly active,
so are just so highly sensitive, so inflamed, easily triggered by chemicals or smells or just overexertion, sometimes it is a mast cell issue and so we need to address it from a histamine perspective, but we also need to address stabilizing those mast cells, so this would be an important one as well since cortisol does have a mast cell stabilizing effect.
This category here is histamine receptor, so this is looking at those receptors on the cell surface and so different ways that if any one of these receptors are triggered, what the response is, and so there's some some specifics here that we can get into when we're looking at individual genetics, but ultimately histamine imbalance is not good.
And can contribute to inflammation, systemic inflammation, and gut health issues, oxalates, so oxalates are found in some of the the healthiest foods that we think of, we think of leafy greens and the spinach in particular can be high in oxalates, so oxalates are in these plants and they are a protective part of the plant.
So when we eat these foods, we are not supposed to absorb the oxalates, the oxalates are just supposed to pass through and be excreted, so if we have the leaky gut scenario oxalates can be entered into the bloodstream, if we have genetic variance here in these few upcoming categories, that is another way that we can absorb too many oxalates when we're not supposed to be doing that.
And when this happens, it can combine with calcium within the blood and it can form crystals, so or stones, crystal stones, so kidney stones, gall stones can be linked to rheumatoid arthritis, some variance here, so we're taking a look at these to assess if we need to monitor or limit some of those foods that can be high in oxalates.
We do have some supplements to help balance this as well, oxalates scavenger can help pull excessive oxalates from the tissue, from the body, oxalate balancer is another one as well if you have genetic variance here.
So depending on if it's a leaky gut issue or if it's a genetic issue, we would make a different supplement recommendation.
The FUT2 gene is a gene that helps us to produce that mucus layer that lines the digestive tract, and again super important to gut health because that mucus layer is really where your the beneficial bacteria within the gut resides, so they take root within that mucus layer and really thrive and flourish.
So if we don't have a healthy mucus layer, we really don't have a diverse microbiome, which we know is very healthy, we need to have a diverse microbiome.
And so the FUT2 gene is very important in that scenario, so again, we could be giving you all of the wonderful probiotics that there are available, but if you don't have this healthy layer, then these probiotics are not able to take root and be beneficial to your health.
So that's where prebiotics are important, so we need to be feeding this layer with healthy prebiotic fibers, you know, bananas that are a little underripe, so bananas that are more green are higher in prebiotic fiber, artichokes, leaks, onions, garlic, so those are some prebiotic fibers, we do have supplements that contain prebiotic fibers.
So one of the ones that we use quite often is called sun spectrum, so it's got the prebiotic fiber, and it has probiotics does have some curcumin in, so it works as an anti-inflammatory, and then it also has coq10, so antioxidant benefit as well.
So we use that a lot, another option would be something called clear SBI pro, so that is great to support the mucus layer, it also has a component that binds onto toxins within the gut and can help pull them out of the system.
So fats, carbs, and proteins, so now we're looking at how the body is digesting, so taking fats, carbs, and proteins from our food, and getting them into that, into the Krebs cycle, so into the mitochondria to produce that ATP that we talked about earlier, so all of these genes are important in all of those steps of getting these macro nutrients into the right forms
to produce acetylcoenzyme A, that is what kicks off the Krebs cycle of getting these micronutrients into the mitochondria, so we have to have all of these functioning in order to have adequate amounts of acetylcoenzyme A, if you have a lot of variance in these genes, you might be somebody who has kind of chronically experienced fatigue, you just don't have energy,
and that would make a lot of sense, because if we're not able to get the nutrients into the mitochondria, we don't have enough ATP to perform functions, so fatigue and certainly then disease is more likely to develop when our cells can't do what they are, do the necessary functions, perform the necessary functions, so this isn't a big one.
A lot of times, some individual genes are found multiple places throughout the genetic report, this PEMT is one of those, so this is a gene that helps us to create coline.
Coline is a precursor for phosphatidal coline, and this is really important in the cell membrane, so this gene is important to the integrity of the cell membrane, the cell membrane consists of a phospholipid by layer, so we need fats in the right forms in order to create the membrane,
and have cellular membrane integrity, so important here, and also important, coline is important for brain health, for liver function, and also important in the diet section here for helping to digest fats.
The FADS gene as well is important in digestion and breakdown of fats, getting them into the right components here for ATP production.
Fats are really what give us the most bang for our buck as far as ATP production, so again we want to make sure we're getting those healthy fats within the diet, the omega-3s are the healthy fats, the anti-inflammatory fats,
with the standard American diet, we're getting way too many of the omega-6 fats, and we need to have these in the right ratio, so really we need to support people by getting more omega-3s into the diet, so taking a fish oil or an omega-3 supplement can be helpful here,
if there's variants here, we do have a supplement called fatty acid assist, which really helps to get fats to break down into those right components to get them into the mitochondria, so that could be a great supplement as well.
This gene here is involved in long-chain polyunsaturated fatty acid synthesis, so we look at that, this one here, this TNF gene, it is an important gene that helps us with fats, lipid metabolism, but it's also an important inflammatory gene as well, so when you have variants here,
this really favors a scenario where our body just likes that pro-inflammatory state, so we have all of these checks and balances in place, so we have reasons for inflammation, so if we are injured, we have a tissue injury, we twist our ankle or something,
we need to have inflammatory chemicals flooding that area to stabilize it, to flood it with nutrients for healing, so we do need acute inflammation to help heal tissue, stabilize tissue, so we're not prone to twisting the ankle again,
so there's a lot of benefit, it is a necessary component of life to have inflammation to help us get rid of things that aren't supposed to be there, and to heal tissue, but we also need the balancing act, which is the anti-inflammatory signals, and so when we get stuck out of balance with one or the other, really it's not good, it's not desired, so we're trying to manage this,
but we have variants here, if we have variants here, the body is really favoring that pro-inflammatory state, so we need to work hard, flooding the body with anti-inflammatory signals, so just again, it's kind of a holistic approach for everything, because we can be causing inflammatory situations just from our environment, from the air we're breathing, from the water we're drinking,
certainly from the food choices that we are making, so we need to kind of have all systems on deck and explore all avenues to reduce inflammation holistically, especially when we have variants here.
Now, this right here you might be wondering, it says NA, so once in a while it doesn't happen very often, but obviously in this case it did when we're in, when they are testing and analyzing the DNA from each sample, sometimes there can be not enough DNA or something has been compromised, and they can't get a good read for a particular gene.
Again, it does not happen very often, but once in a while it comes up with this not available marker for a particular gene, so that's what is indicated there.
The pink gene is a rate limiting step in production of coenzyme A, so again, this is related to the mitochondria and in getting ATP production, so if we have variants here, we're really slow producers of coenzyme A, so we don't have efficient production of ATP, so we need to manage and address that.
This gene here relates to carnitine fat, you know fatty acid metabolism, carnitine is important for that.
The ACAT gene is also an important one for lipid fats and protein synthesis.
So if we have variants here, we're not taking the fats and the proteins from our diet and getting the ATP that we should from that, so we might need a digestive enzyme.
People with variants here might not do well with a keto-like diet, so they might need to be on a different diet.
Let's see here, the APOE gene is a gene that you may have heard of, it's the one that is most linked to risk for Alzheimer's disease, and it really has to do with the body's ability to manage lipids, so it has to do with triglyceride levels.
And so we have to manage that with just by dietary sources, so depending on the variants that you have here, you can see there's two versions of this APOE gene, and then we can look over here and see what version we have.
So when we're looking at the genotype, so this person with no variants on either category here, this person is a TT and a CC, and so then we follow that down to these columns here, and we see OK, TT CC.
So this person is an E3E3, so this is the normal expression of this gene, if you have some of the variants, so the APOE4 gene is the one that's most linked to risk of Alzheimer's disease, and so that would be one of these issues you can have an E3 and an E4, or you could have the double variant and have both E4s.
And so we want to monitor, be careful with that, we need to increase, you know, exercise, we need to stay away from saturated fats.
Coconut oil is a saturated fat, it's solid at room temperature, but coconut oil does not digest and process the same way as, you know, saturated fats that you might be getting from animal protein.
And so coconut oil is beneficial and helpful, but so lots of things that kind of wraps up our our digestive section of the genetic report here's lots of things that we can do to help manage gut health and reduce the likelihood of inflammatory situations and increase health overall.
So I hope that that helps when you guys are looking at your genetic report and stay tuned for more sections. Have a good day.